bonjour à tous l'iphone dit qu'on ferait
des problèmes de charge par induction
vous risqueriez de voir la vie de votre
batterie franchement diminué en
utilisant la recharge par induction sur
l'iphone 10 et je vais vous expliquer
tout de suite pourquoi
le problème était pointée du doigt par
adrian kingsley yoox de zdnet
en effet lorsque vous rechargez votre
iphone 10 par l'induction vous avez un
vrai problème au niveau de la longévité
de votre batterie le nombre de cycles a
tendance à baisser drastiquement et du
coup la durée de vie de vos batteries
d'être vraiment diminué en moins de six
mois il a constaté qu'ils étaient déjà à
135,6 la durée de vie complète d'une
batterie pour apple c'est 506 à leur
charge et à fond elle décharge est à
fond 500 fois au bout de cent fois votre
batterie apte à peu près les 80 % de
rendement et à ce moment là il faut
penser elle a changé sauf qu'en six mois
sept personnes déjà fait 135 cycle et
elle a estimé que les 500 cycles elle
les aurait atteint en 18 mois soit même
pas deux ans après avoir arraché son
smartphone donc ça pose effectivement un
vrai problème de longévité du smartphone
alors en effet ces personnes là est une
grande consommatrice de son smartphone
va beaucoup leurs charges et il va
beaucoup des chargées et s'est rendu
compte qu'ils avaient un vrai problème
au niveau de l' usure prématurée en
recharge par induction alors à peu la
dgt dans la tourmente a pas très
longtemps au niveau de ses batteries au
niveau de l'obsolescence programmée j'ai
pas si vous en souvenez je vais déjà
fait une vidéo apple ralentissez
délibérément la machine pour préserver
la batterie une batterie qu'on pouvait
changer pour 79 euros pour l'instant
c'est passé à 29 euros
si ça vous intéresse jusqu'à la fin de
l'année si vous souffrez règlement de ce
problème mais concernant l'iphone dit
c'est fondamentalement une chose
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que si
vous changez uniquement par induction
l'essence ainsi que vous allez passer
très rapidement
même avant deux ans vous allez acheter
un smartphone qui coûtent quasiment 1200
euros c'est quand même un certain prix
en plus de ça il faut acheter la borne
de recharge par induction qui n'est pas
du tout compris dans le prix donc ça
vous a coûté quasiment 1200 euros plus
la borne de recharge par induction
donc au final pour recharger votre
smartphone avec cette nouvelle
technologie qui vous est vendue comme
étant une technologie pas
révolutionnaire parce qu'a déjà connu
ailleurs dans d'autres dans d'autres
marques mais vraiment comme étant un
point fort de ce nouvel iphone 10 vous
vous retrouvez avec un smartphone qui va
être dégradé très rapidement à cause de
la batterie au final vous payez cher et
ça vous coûtera beaucoup plus cher par
la suite parce que vous allez devoir
soit changer la batterie soit changer
votre smartphone
qu'est ce qu'a constaté adrian kings les
de zdnet c'est quelqu'un qui utilise
énormément son iphone et qui forcément
lorsqu'il ya un petit coup de mou leur
charge systématiquement sur ses anciens
modèles cette personne a tendance à le
recharger via le câble lightning et
maintenant elle fait exactement la même
chose mais via la recharge par induction
c'est justement là qu'elle ait fait part
d'air parce que ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que lorsque vous rechargez votre
smartphone via le câble lightning c'est
le courant qui arrivent via le câble qui
fait fonctionner le smartphone et non
pas la batterie elle prend le relais gal
permet à la batterie de surcharger plus
rapidement puisque la batterie n'est pas
utilisé alors lorsque vous la recharger
via l'induction votre batterie va se
recharger sans contact mais c'est bien
votre batterie qui elle va faire tourner
votre smartphone
on prend un exemple bête moi par exemple
lorsque je vais recharger mon smartphone
je le branche le soir et le matin je le
débrancher un smartphone qui est chargé
à 100 % ce qui fait que ma batterie
pendant la nuit n'est pas du tout
sollicité et donc mon smartphone à
pouvoir durer plus longtemps et c'est
complètement différent avec la recharge
par induction puisque mon smartphone est
posée sur sa base et la batterie va en
permanence se charger et se décharger
ce qui fait que la durée de vie va
vraiment être diminuée alors la solution
elle est plutôt simple c'est d'utiliser
uniquement le rechargement via le câble
lightning sauf qu'on vous a vendue un
smartphone pouvant se recharger par
induction et que vous allez pouvoir
garder longtemps et on vous a pas du
tout dit d'ailleurs ça n'est pas
forcément été vu par apple qu'il y
aurait un défaut du point de vue de la
recharge sans fil
du coup vous vous retrouvez avec un
produit que vous avez payé cher avec un
vieillissement prématuré et vous vous
lavez vous voyez ce que je veux dire on
pourrait se dire que ce problème de
recharge par induction va toucher tout
le monde mais à priori non puisque
samsung a dit que ça ne touchait pas du
tout ils utilisent leur chargement sans
fil pour la gamme ds depuis plusieurs
années et il certifie notamment depuis
les problèmes avec le note 7 que leur
recharge sans fil et leurs batteries
avait vraiment une très bonne longévité
donc effectivement c'est un problème qui
touche apple est ce que c'est un
problème d'optimisation de l'ol de la
batterie pendant la recharge
ça sent quand on suit un petit peu
encore obscures ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est un nouveau coup dur pour apple
après tous les problèmes de batterie
pointée du doigt avec comme ce sens ce
programme et on se retrouve maintenant
avec un problème de batterie dû à la
recharge par induction pour des produits
premium qui coûte quand même plus de
1000 euros avec du matériel acheté en
plus c'est vraiment problématique pour
l'instant apple a plutôt tendance à
gérer la crise à ce bien effectivement
sur les problèmes de longévité de
batteries par rapport au peuple a par
rapport à l'obsolescence programmée
il propose de remplacer les bas
et en fonction des besoins en proposant
des tarifs beaucoup plus bas
ça risque effectivement d'être le cas
également sur l'iphone dise ce qu'il
faudrait réellement c'est que apple
décide de prendre les problèmes à la
source
quel est le problème avec leurs
batteries quel est le problème de
longévité est vraiment le solutionner
une bonne fois pour toutes pour que les
utilisateurs n'est pas à passer à la
caisse pour changer leurs batteries
dans tous les cas c'est une vraie crise
de confiance pour apple et pour tous les
utilisateurs d'iphone disent tous les
utilisateurs des anciens iphone s'était
déjà effectivement relativement
compliqué là il ya un nouveau problème
qu'est ce tu rajoutes est ce qu'apple va
réussir à continuer à gagner la
confiance des utilisateurs avec des
vrais problèmes importants puisque la
batterie de toute façon c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est au coeur de votre
smartphone si votre batterie marche pas
60' ne va pas marcher non plus très
longtemps je voulais vous en parler
parce que je pense que c'est vraiment un
problème très important vous êtes
probablement nombreux à voir iphone 10 à
utiliser la recharge par induction
je vous conseille de faire très
attention si vous rechargez dès qu'il
est plein enlevez le ne laissait pas sur
le socle est privilégié la recharge par
le câble lightning
ça vous évitera des déconvenues est
d'abord un smartphone qui sera mort au
bout d'un an et demi et ça à mon avis ça
en fera râler plus dans dit man vous ce
que vous en pensez est-ce que vous
continuez à avoir confiance à apple
est ce que ces poids qui sont pointés du
doigt vous pose vraiment problème est ce
que vous avez toujours confiance en
apple confiance en leur matériel en
leurs produits en leur capacité
solutionner les problèmes
je vous invite bien évidemment à me
répondre à tout ça en commentaire comme
d'habitude vous invite à vous abonner à
menacer des jolies pouce parce qu'on a
toujours plus parler de thèmes
d'actualité des faits des sujets comme
ça qui sont chauds et qui vous concerne
on va en parler dix images bien c'est de
regarder cette nouvelle vidéo vous
embrasse il ya très bientôt soyez sage
et surtout restez connectés lillo
bisaccia au total
[Musique]